This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The turn of the year is a time when we set the old aside and welcome the new into our lives. And so today we bring you a tale of loss and renewal from December 2015. It appeals to me for two reasons. The first is it's a universal story. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. You know, I was first and foremost a violinist. The second reason is that this is also about social science research and its applications in the real world. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。岁末年初是一个我们将过去抛诸脑后、迎接新生事物进入生活的时刻。因此，今天我们为您带来一个2015年12月关于失去与重生的故事。这个故事吸引我有两个原因。首先，这是一个普遍的故事。我真的为失去了一件我完全热爱、充满激情、并且真正构成了我的生活和身份很大一部分的东西而感到崩溃。你知道的，我首先是一名小提琴手。第二个原因是，这也关乎社会科学研究及其在现实世界中的应用。我们发现，大学入学率提高了9%。
As a result of 8 text messages. I mean that is really profound. 8 text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Today we're telling you a story that begins in the attic of a home in Connecticut and ends at the White House. And on our theme of loss and reinvention, we'll bring you a poem I came across
仅仅因为8条短信。我的意思是，这真的很深远。8条短信就是我平常任何一天发给我最好的朋友的信息量。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。今天我们要为您讲述一个始于康涅狄格州一栋房子的阁楼、终于白宫的故事。顺应我们关于失去与重塑的主题，我们将为您朗诵我偶然读到的一首诗
from Elizabeth Bishop, read by musician Amy Mann. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster. My grandmother was an Indian classical violinist and so my mom had her old violin and our attic for many years. This is Maya Shankar, no relation. Each of my three older siblings had rejected the violin saying that it wasn't cool enough and my mom finally gave me the instrument and I was immediately taken kind of by the tactile sensation of the instrument.
作者是伊丽莎白·毕晓普，由音乐家艾米·曼恩朗读。然后练习更远、更快地失去，地点、名字以及你原本打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。我的祖母是一位印度古典小提琴手，所以我妈妈的阁楼里多年来一直放着她那把旧小提琴。我是玛雅·尚卡尔，与他们没有亲属关系。我的三个哥哥姐姐都曾拒绝过这把小提琴，说它不够酷，我妈妈最终把这把乐器交给了我，而我立刻就被这种乐器的触觉所吸引。
I mean the wood and the bow. I just loved the feeling of playing the violin. Even as a child, Maya immediately loved everything about the violin. The way it looked, the way it felt, the way it sounded. Maya's mother didn't know much about western classical music, but she signed up her daughter for lessons using the Suzuki method. The focus was on playing by ear and making beautiful sound. Maya practiced constantly. I had a special scheduled school to lump all my classes together so that I come a little bit early and get a little bit more practice in, and especially with all the traveling, most days were devoted exclusively to music. She got good, very good.
我是说木头和琴弓。我就是喜欢拉小提琴的感觉。即使在孩提时代，玛雅也立刻爱上了小提琴的一切。它的外观、它的触感、它的声音。玛雅的母亲对西方古典音乐并不太了解，但她用铃木教学法为女儿报了小提琴课。重点是通过听觉演奏并发出美妙的声音。玛雅不断地练习。我有一个特殊的学校日程安排，把所有的课都集中在一起，这样我可以早一点到，多练习一会儿，尤其是伴随着各种奔波，大多数日子基本上都是专属于音乐的。她变得很好，非常优秀。
Now the part of her musical education that was missing was the formal part. She didn't know how to read music very well, but she had a fine ear, and she had ambition. In the pursuit to find a teacher who would take her to the next level, Maya's mother did something quite daring. Yeah, so my mom, she was really a go-getter when it came to my violin life because, like I said, she didn't really have a lot of experience or exposure to the music community and kind of had to innovate in order to find opportunities. There were a New York one day close to the Juilliard school, one of the world's most famous and
现在，她音乐教育中缺失的部分是正规的部分。她不太会识谱，但她有一双敏锐的耳朵，而且她很有野心。为了寻找能带她走向更高水平的老师，玛雅的母亲做出了一件非常大胆的事。是的，所以我的妈妈，她在我的小提琴生涯中真的是个行动派，因为就像我说的，她其实并没有太多的音乐界经验或接触，为了寻找机会不得不进行创新。有一天，她们在纽约，离茱莉亚学院很近，这是世界上最著名和
exclusive music institutions, when her mother came up with an idea, she said, Why don't we just go to Juilliard? I mean, why not? What can we lose? Just walk in the door. We just walked in. So we walked into the building and just by happenstance, we happened to run into a student in the elevator who studied with a music teacher and my mom talked to that family and the elevator and said, would you mind if we just had about five or ten minutes at the end of your lesson where Maya could play for your teacher? And they were really gracious and they said, sure, no problem.
最独特的音乐院校之一，当时她的母亲突然冒出一个想法，她说，我们为什么不直接去茱莉亚呢？我是说，为什么不呢？我们有什么好失去的？直接走进大门就行。我们真的就走进去了。于是我们走进了大楼，非常巧合的是，我们在电梯里碰巧遇到了一位学生，他跟随一位音乐老师学习，我妈妈在电梯里和那个家庭交谈，并说，你们介不介意在你们上完课后，给我们大约五到十分钟的时间，让玛雅为你们的老师演奏一次？他们非常大方，说，当然，没问题。
Of course, you know what happened next. Maya played for the other students' music teacher, wilded the teacher, and got accepted into a summer program. Soon she was taking classes at Juilliard. She was playing with other talented musicians. She was even being featured on NPR. Joining us now is the Juilliard Pre-College violin quartet. They are 17-year-old Emily Jen Run from Glassden-Bray, Connecticut.
当然，你知道接下来发生了什么。玛雅为其他学生的音乐老师演奏了，惊艳了这位老师，并被一个暑期项目录取了。很快她就在茱莉亚学院上课了。她开始和其他有才华的音乐家一起演奏。她甚至登上了美国国家公共电台（NPR）的节目。现在加入我们的是茱莉亚学院大学预科小提琴四重奏。他们是来自康涅狄格州格拉斯登布雷的17岁女孩艾米丽·简·鲁恩。
15-year-old Maya Shankar from Cheshire, Connecticut. Maya, by the way, is a from-the-top veteran. She's been with us since the early 50s. That was Maya on NPR's from-the-top. She had found her classical music home. She was talented, hard-working, and the path before her seemed clear. I really wanted to be a violinist. I was so passionate about it. I never felt more comfortable than when I was performing. For some reason, that's where I experienced flow. And the ability to spend a lot of time practicing
来自康涅狄格州柴郡的15岁女孩玛雅·尚卡尔。顺便说一句，玛雅是“From the Top”节目的老手了。她从50年代初就和我们在一起了。那是玛雅在NPR的“From the Top”节目中的表现。她找到了她的古典音乐归宿。她很有天赋，工作努力，眼前的道路似乎很清晰。我真的很想成为一名小提琴手。我对它充满激情。每当我在表演时，我从未感到如此自在。出于某种原因，那就是我体验到心流的地方。以及花费大量时间练习的特权
and trying to perfect the art, and then you go on stage, and you kind of just surrender. And you play to the best of your abilities. There was just something beautiful and elegant about that process and I just really, really loved it. She was so good and so enthusiastic that opportunities kept presenting themselves. One day her teacher at Juliet arranged for her to play
并试图完善这种艺术，然后你走上舞台，你有点只是臣服于它。你尽你所能地去演奏。那个过程中有某种美丽而优雅的东西，我真的、真的很喜欢它。她太优秀、太热情了，以至于各种机会不断向她走来。有一天，她在茱莉亚学院的老师安排她去为
for a famous violinist, a very famous violinist. I nearly fell over in my seat because no reasonable musician thinks they're gonna get the opportunity to meet its octoproleman, let alone play for its octoproleman. Do you remember what you played? I played the barber violin The The The The The The The
一位著名的小提琴手演奏，一位非常著名的小提琴手。我差点从座位上摔下来，因为没有哪个理智的音乐家会认为自己有机会遇到帕尔曼，更不用说为帕尔曼演奏了。你还记得你当时拉的是什么吗？我拉的是巴伯小提琴协奏曲……
The The The The The The The The The The The
……
The The The The The The The as a student. In addition to Saturdays, I was also going to New York multiple times during the week, either for studio classes at his home in Manhattan or for private lessons or chamber music lessons, and at that point it was very clear to me that I wanted to become a concert violinist. Well, I remember that she sounded, she had a very lovely, we're making music, and that's for me, a resource, the most important thing. To concert violinist Itzak Pearlman, it was okay that Maya had learned to play music by ear rather than by reading music. The technical stuff was important, but it could be learned. You know, it's more important for me to have somebody musical. And let's say that the
……作为一名学生。除了周六，我还在一周内多次前往纽约，去他在曼哈顿的家中上工作室课程、上私教课或室内乐课，在那一刻，我非常清楚地知道，我想成为一名音乐会小提琴家。嗯，我记得她的声音，她有一种非常可爱的……我们在创作音乐，对我来说，这是一个资源，最最重要的事。对于音乐会小提琴家伊扎克·帕尔曼来说，玛雅是通过听觉而不是通过识谱来学习音乐，这是可以接受的。技术方面的东西很重要，但是是可以学会的。你知道的，对我来说，拥有一个有音乐感的人更重要。比方说，在
technique wise has, you know, you have to work on the technique, but the important thing is the music. And I felt that you had a very lovely way of phrasing and so on and so forth. And so we worked on that, but then we also worked on, you know, how do you accomplish technically certain things. For example, in the barbure concert, the last movement is a little bit tricky. So how do you practice that? But Perlman didn't just teach Maya how to play the violin. He taught her something much more important. How to teach herself to play the violin. I remember lots of lessons were, instead of telling me, Maya, okay, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase. Here's what you should do to make
技术方面，你知道的，你必须在技术上下功夫，但重要的是音乐。我觉得你有一种非常可爱的分句方式等等。所以我们在这方面下了功夫，但我们也研究了，你知道的，如何在技术上完成某些事情。例如，在巴伯协奏曲中，最后一个乐章有点棘手。那么你如何练习那个部分呢？但帕尔曼不仅教玛雅如何拉小提琴。他教给了她更重要的东西。如何自学拉小提琴。我记得有很多次课，他不是直接告诉我，玛雅，好吧，显然你对那个乐句不满意。你应该这样做来让
it better. He would instead say, Maya, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase, what do you think you should do in order to make that phrase better? Let's talk about it. Let me hear what your aspirations are for the arc of this musical phrase. What tools do you have at your disposal, either with your bow arm or your vibrato or your tone, in order to make it beautiful? And it's really frustrating. I mean, in the moment, you're thinking, okay, man, like, you're the expert here, you know? Just tell me what to do. Please just tell me what to do and make this easier for both of us. So the more you learn, the more to think for yourself and to try and solve problems on your own,
它变得更好。相反，他会说，玛雅，显然你对那个乐句不满意，你认为你应该怎么做才能让那个乐句变得更好？我们来讨论一下。让我听听你对这个乐句走向的期望是什么。你拥有什么工具，无论是你的弓臂、揉弦还是音色，来让它变得优美？这真的很令人沮丧。我是说，在那一刻，你在想，好吧，老兄，你是这方面的专家，你知道吗？直接告诉我该怎么做。请直接告诉我该怎么做，让咱们俩都轻松点。所以你学得越多，越是去独立思考并尝试自己解决问题，
the better it is for you for the future. It was all going so well. When Maya was 15, she was practicing at a program run by its sock parliament. And I was playing a passage from a very challenging Paganini Caprice. And I simply overstretched my finger on one note, and I felt kind of a popping. And so I overstretched the tendon, and it didn't really heal as expected. And so how did you spend the next months?
对你的未来就越好。一切都进展得那么顺利。玛雅15岁时，在一个由伊扎克·帕尔曼运营的项目中练习。当时我正在演奏帕格尼尼随想曲中一个非常具有挑战性的乐段。我只是在一个音符上过度伸展了手指，然后我感觉到了一种轻微的爆裂声。于是我过度拉伸了肌腱，它并没有像预期那样愈合。那么你接下来的几个月是怎么度过的呢？
What did you do? Well, Mr. Prolement was such a gem because I injured my left hand. He continued to teach me violin just with my bow arm. So for over a year I went to him and we just worked on perfecting my bow arm and I would just play open strings in every lesson. And he would teach me about how to produce pretty beautiful sound. You know, you always feel that, you know, it will resolve itself. So usually what happens if one hand doesn't particularly, you know, respond or anything like this, you work on the other hand just, you know, not to waste time just to do so if you've got your left hand that has a problem that you work on the right hand, just, you know, not to waste time just to do so if you've got your left hand,
你做了什么？嗯，帕尔曼先生真是太好了，因为我的左手受伤了。他继续只用我的弓臂教我拉小提琴。所以有一年多的时间我去找他，我们只是在完善我的弓臂，每一节课我都只拉空弦。他教我如何发出美妙动听的声音。你知道的，你总会觉得，你知道的，这会自己恢复的。所以通常发生的情况是，如果一只手特别没有，你知道的，有反应或类似的事情，你就会专注于另一手，你知道的，为了不浪费时间只是去做，如果你左手有问题，你就专注于右手，你知道的，为了不浪费时间只是去做，如果你左手有问题，
that's a problem that you work on the right hand and vice versa. It's good, you know, her attitude was, you know, I mean, obviously she wasn't, I mean, I'm sure that she was feeling good about it, but it was never like what's to use. Maya's hand didn't heal. Doctors finally told her she had to stop playing completely. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life
那是右手的问题，反之亦然。这很好，你知道，她的态度是，你知道的——我的意思是，很显然她不是——我的意思是，我确信她当时感觉挺好的，但从来没有那种“有什么用”的感觉。玛雅的手没有痊愈。医生最终告诉她，她必须完全停止演奏。我真的为失去了一件我完全热爱、充满激情、并且真正构成了我的生活和身份很大一部分的东西而感到崩溃
and my identity, you know. I was first and foremost a violinist. And so I was anxious because I was worried that I would never find something that I felt as passionately about as I did with music. Just like that, Maya's dream to become a concert violinist was over. Back home for the summer in Connecticut, she started to ask herself how she could pick up the pieces, would she ever find anything that could make her as happy as the violin?
和我的身份，你知道的。我首先是一名小提琴手。因此我很焦虑，因为我担心我再也找不到像音乐那样让我充满激情的东西了。就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴手的梦想破灭了。回到康涅狄格州过暑假后，她开始问自己该如何收拾残局，她还能找到能让她像小提琴那样快乐的东西吗？
Our next guest appeared as a violinist on a pilot episode when she was just 12 years old. She's now 23 and during those intervening years, well, brace yourself because what she's accomplished is a little humbling to us mere mortals. Please welcome Maya Shankar. Applause To find out what Maya did, stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan.
我们的下一位嘉宾在12岁时曾作为小提琴手出演试播集。她现在23岁了，在过去的那些年里，嗯，请做好心理准备，因为她所取得的成就让我们这些凡人感到有点自惭形秽。欢迎玛雅·尚卡尔。掌声 想知道玛雅做了什么，请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
On our last podcast of the year, we're exploring the idea of closing the book on one chapter of your life and opening another. We're doing it through the story of Maya Shankar. After learning she could no longer play the violin due to an injury to her left hand, Maya retreated to her parents' home in Connecticut. Her life felt indiscery. The summer before, doctors basically told me I had to stop playing completely. And just by luck, I was helping my parents clean their basement in Cheshire, Connecticut, and I stumbled
在我们今年的最后一期播客中，我们将探讨合上你生命中的一个章节并开启另一个章节的想法。我们通过玛雅·尚卡尔的故事来探讨这一点。在得知由于左手受伤而无法再拉小提琴后，玛雅退回了父母在康涅狄格州的家中。她的生活感觉支离破碎。前一个夏天，医生基本上告诉我必须完全停止演奏。而纯属偶然的是，我当时正在帮父母清理位于康涅狄格州柴郡的地下室，我偶然
upon an old coursebook of my sister's, it was called The Language Instinct by Stephen Pinker. Maya started reading, and the more she read, the more excited she became. It was remarkable for me to learn about just how complex our minds were and just what was required in order for us to have our day-to-day experiences. And so it really wet my appetite for learning more about the mind and for exploring and more depth, kind of the brilliance of the brain. She started to study cognitive science. She went on to get her PhD at Oxford on a Rhodes scholarship.
翻到了一本我姐姐的旧教科书，它叫斯蒂芬·平克的《语言本能》。玛雅开始阅读，她读得越多，就越兴奋。了解我们的心灵是多么复杂，以及为了拥有日常体验究竟需要什么，对我来说真是太非凡了。所以它确实激起了我更多地了解心灵、更深入地探索大脑的辉煌的胃口。她开始研究认知科学。她获得了罗德奖学金，去牛津大学攻读博士学位。
She got a postdoctoral fellowship, a promising career in academia lay ahead of her. But here again, came another unexpected turn. So over Thanksgiving break of the final year of my postdoc, I was at home and I was visiting my undergraduate advisor from college, named Laurie Santos, and she was telling me about the U.S. Department of Agriculture's efforts to get free and reduced price lunches, school lunches, into the hands of more eligible students.
她获得了博士后奖学金，学术界一条充满前途的职业道路在她面前展开。但在这里，又迎来了另一个意想不到的转折。所以在我的博士后最后一年感恩节假期期间，我在家拜访了我在大学时的本科生导师，名叫劳瑞·桑托斯，她向我讲述了美国农业部为让更多符合条件的贫困学生吃上免费和减价午餐——学校午餐——所做出的努力。
Students were going hungry because the process of getting certified for the lunch program was cumbersome. The Department of Agriculture came up with a simple idea. Instead of having a multi-step sign-up system, states could use information they already had about poor families to help enroll children in the lunch program. And it's just a matter of data matching and cross-enrolling these students. But as a result of this common sense reform, you know, 12.4 million students as of 2015 were automatically enrolled into the school lunch program and had access to lunches and were able to thrive at school.
学生们正在挨饿，因为获得午餐项目认证的过程繁琐。农业部想出了一个简单的想法。各州不用多步骤的注册系统，而是可以使用它们已经拥有的关于贫困家庭的信息来帮助儿童注册午餐项目。这只关乎数据匹配和跨项目注册这些学生。但由于这项常识性的改革，你知道，截至2015年，有1240万学生自动注册了学校午餐项目，获得了午餐，并能够在学校茁壮成长。
And I remember being so moved by this example. Dumaia, it was magical. It was just like a light bulb went off in my head and I thought, okay, this is what I need to be doing with my life. I want to be taking research insights from the behavioral sciences and allowing them to find their way into public policy so that they can be in the service of Americans and people around the world.
我记得这个例子深深打动了我。对玛雅来说，这太神奇了。就像我的脑海里亮起了一盏灯，我想，好吧，这就是我一生中需要做的事。我想把行为科学的研究见解融入公共政策中，让它们服务于美国人和世界各地的人们。
So how do you break into the world of policy when you're just a lowly post-doc? Maya knew nothing of politics. She didn't have connections in the world of government. But she did remember a lesson her mother had taught her standing outside the Juilliard school years earlier. She tracked down an email address for Thomas Kalea who was helping the Obama administration with its science policy.
那么，当你只是一个低微的博士后时，如何闯入政策的世界呢？玛雅对政治一无所知。她在政府界没有任何人脉。但她确实记得她母亲多年前在茱莉亚学院门外教给她的一个教训。她找到了托马斯·卡利（Thomas Kalil）的电子邮箱，他当时正在协助奥巴马政府制定科学政策。
I sent Tom again a cold email. This is the Juilliard method again. This is my mom's dulyard. I get to give her full credit for this. She is totally fearless and kind of inspired this trait. And I went over to his home and he asked me to pitch to him ideas that I had around interventions where behavioral science could improve public policy outcomes. What did you tell him? I talked to him about a number of things like the
我又给汤姆发了一封盲发邮件。这又是茱莉亚方法。这是我妈妈的茱莉亚方法。我得把全部功劳归功于她。她完全无所畏惧，某种程度上启发了这种特质。我去了他家，他让我向他推介我关于干预措施的想法，这些干预措施可以用行为科学改善公共政策结果。你跟他说了什么？我跟他谈了很多事情，比如
importance of using social norms to motivate behavior. So we know from research that if you tell people that their neighbors use less energy than they do, right? They're more likely to use less energy. And there's a lot of domains in which just telling people what the data shows about people's actions and decisions can actually drive actions that are more in alignment with people's long-term goals or with policy objectives. And something that struck me about that conversation is I had been talking for years with my academic colleagues about the potential applications of using behavioral insights
利用社会规范来激励行为的重要性。所以我们从研究中知道，如果你告诉人们他们的邻居比他们用更少的能源，对吧？他们更有可能使用更少的能源。在许多领域，仅仅告诉人们数据展示了人们的行为和决策，实际上就可以推动更符合人们长期目标或政策目标的行动。那次对话中让我印象深刻的一件事是，多年来我一直与我的学术同仁讨论利用行为见解
to improve people's lives. And this was the first time that when I told him an idea that I had, his response was, oh, we can find a way to do that. Maya joined the White House. She was asked to put together a team that could marshal ideas from social science research and apply them to public policy challenges. You've had a chance in your current role to actually work on this project that started you on this mission, the school lunch program. Can you tell me a little bit about that? So we have been working with the U.S. Department of Agriculture and also
来改善人们生活的潜在应用。这是我第一次向他讲述我的想法时，他的回应是：“哦，我们可以找到办法做到这一点。”玛雅加入了白宫。她被要求组建一个团队，能够汇集社会科学研究的想法，并将其应用于公共政策挑战。你在当前的角色中有机会实际参与这个让你走上这项使命的项目，即学校午餐项目。能跟我多讲讲这个吗？我们一直在与美国农业部以及
local school districts to redesign communications that they're sending to families to help promote the verification process so that their kids can stay on the benefit. So we've done a few things. So there's a few behavioral insights that we've used. One is we've taken a very long list of action steps required for verification and condense them into three easy to understand steps that you can take. Two, we've worked with school districts to translate the communications into multiple languages in order to support comprehension among the diverse population that this program serves. One issue is that at present families might only think the way to recertify or to verify their information
当地学区合作，重新设计他们发送给家庭的通知，以帮助推动核实流程，以便他们的孩子可以继续享受福利。所以我们做了几件事。所以我们使用了一些行为见解。一是我们将验证所需的很长的行动步骤清单精简为你可以采取的三个易于理解的步骤。二是，我们与学区合作，将通知翻译成多种语言，以支持该项目服务的不同人群的理解。一个问题是，目前家庭可能只认为重新认证或验证他们信息的唯一方法
is to send snail mail or to verify their information is to send snail mail back to the school district. And instead, there's the opportunity for them to take a picture of their information using their mobile phones and actually email it back. And we simply notified people of the opportunity to go through that process. And then in other instances, we included prepaid envelopes to help ease the process of verifying eligibility. So I'm trying to think about why it is we often have trouble sort of thinking about programs
是寄纸质信件，或者验证他们信息的唯一方法是寄纸质信件回学区。相反，他们有机会使用手机拍下他们的信息并将其电邮回来。我们只是将这个可以走此流程的机会通知了人们。在其他情况下，我们附上了预付费信封，以帮助简化验证资格的过程。所以我在思考，为什么我们经常难以思考类似这样的项目
like this because as someone who has been interested in human behavior for a while, it seems to me that programs like these really are, you know, no pun intended, a no brainer, that this is really something that we should be doing. It seems obvious that we should be doing it. But I think part of the issue is that I think many people might say, if you want to stay in a program that's giving you benefits, and these are the steps you need to do in order to get the benefits, and you deserve those benefits, rationally speaking, you should be willing to do those steps in order to get the benefits. And I think it fails to take into account the difference between how human beings are
因为作为一个对人类行为感兴趣了一段时间的人来说，在我看来，像这样的项目真的是，双关语意，不费脑子的事，这真的是我们应该做的事情。显而易见，我们应该这样做。但我认为部分问题在于，我认为许多人可能会说，如果你想留在给你福利的项目中，这些是你为了获得福利需要做出的步骤，而你应得这些福利，从理性上讲，你应该愿意采取这些步骤来获得福利。我认为这没有考虑到人类被假设表现得像理性生物与他们实际表现如何之间的差异。
supposed to behave as rational creatures and how they actually behave. And I feel like that's the central divide that your work is trying to bridge. And I think additionally, you know, the onus is on the government to present information clearly, to present choices clearly, so that people understand what program exists and what their options are and can make the best decisions for themselves and their families. But there's one example that I wanted to point to, which is a phenomenon known as summer melt. This is the phenomenon where talented high school students who are on track to go to college at the start of the summer somehow lose their way and don't show up at college in the fall. Maya and her team have worked on simple, low-cost interventions that can help these students
而我觉得这正是你的工作试图弥合的核心鸿沟。我认为此外，你知道，政府有责任清晰地呈现信息，清晰地呈现选择，以便人们了解存在什么节目以及他们的选择是什么，并为自己和家人做出最佳决策。但我想指出一个例子，这是一个被称为“暑期消融”的现象。这是一种现象，即在夏天开始时有望上大学的优秀高中生不知怎么地迷失了方向，秋天却没有出现在大学里。玛雅和她的团队一直在研究简单、低成本的干预措施，可以帮助这些学生
get to college. Their idea, send the students eight text messages over the summer, reminding them of impending deadlines. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of eight text messages. I mean, that is really profound. 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of eight text messages, I mean, that is really profound. Eight text messages is what I send my best friend
上大学。他们的想法是，在夏天给学生发送八条短信，提醒他们即将到来的截止日期。我们发现大学入学率提高了9%。仅仅因为八条短信。我的意思是，这真的很深远。大学入学率提高了9%。仅仅因为八条短信，我的意思是，这真的很深远。八条短信就是我平常任何一天发给我最好的朋友
on any given day. It seems to me that what you did and what happened to you is actually happens to lots of people all the time where doors close and they feel like it's unbearable that this door is closed because this is where I thought I lived and then another door opens and you realize there are actually many, many houses in which we can live. I think that's exactly right.
的信息量。在我看来，你所做的事以及发生在你身上的事，实际上一直都在许多人身上发生，那就是大门关闭了，他们觉得这扇门关闭是无法忍受的，因为这就是我以为我生活的地方，然后另一扇门打开了，你意识到实际上有非常非常多的房子可以让我们居住。我想完全是这样。
And I think one thing that violin, one of the great blessings of playing the violin is that it allowed me to see what it really felt like to be in love with something and to be really passionate about something. And so if anything, you see sort of features or traits that are extracted in you from engaging with that pursuit. And then your hope is that in the new explorations, those disciplines or those areas can extract those same qualities from you.
而且我认为一件事是小提琴，拉小提琴的一大福分在于它让我看到了真正爱上某事并对某事充满激情是什么感觉。所以如果有什么不同的话，你会看到通过参与这项追求，在你身上被提取出来的特征或特质。然后你的希望是，在新的探索中，这些学科或这些领域可以从你身上提取出相同的品质。
I'm wondering as you think about your own life, do you feel that your career now has been set? This is the house you're going to live in forever. Do you actually believe, on the other hand, that there might be many other houses you will one day come to live in? Well, I've certainly never been happier than I am right now working in public service and using my background to help improve people's lives. So I think that that will continue to be a common theme of whatever it is that I end up doing and working in. That said, I think there are so many ways in which that passion can manifest, right?
我在想，当你思考你自己的生活时，你觉得你的职业现在已经定型了吗？这就是你将永远居住的房子？另一方面，你真的相信有一天可能会有许多其他房子供你居住吗？嗯，从事公共服务并用我的背景帮助改善人们的生活，我当然从未比现在更快乐过。所以我认为这将继续成为我最终所做和从事的任何事情的共同主题。话虽如此，我认为这种激情可以通过多种方式体现出来，对吧？
And I think that one thing the past has taught me is that the world has endless opportunities to positively impact people's lives. And along the way, I might explore various different paths in order to get there. But as long as I stick to that core value of trying to help people and improve people's lives, I think that there are many ways to do that. And of course, you have the cold-called Julia Admeta to aid you. Yeah.
我认为过去教给我的一件事是，世界有无数的机会对人们的生活产生积极影响。在这个过程中，为了达到目标，我可能会探索各种不同的道路。但只要我坚持试图帮助人们和改善人们生活的核心价值观，我认为有很多方法可以做到这一点。当然，你还有盲发邮件的茱莉亚方法来帮助你。是的。
So I think that, yeah, again, thanks to my mom, I think that there is always that full-proof method of the standard cold-call. That was Maya Shankar. She served as senior advisor for the social and behavioral sciences at the White House Office of Science and Technology Policy on the President Obama. Since then, Maya has left the White House and become Google's first head of behavioral insights.
所以我想，是的，再次感谢我妈妈，我认为标准的盲发邮件那种万无一失的方法永远存在。那是玛雅·尚卡尔。她曾担任奥巴马总统时期白宫科学和技术政策办公室社会和行为科学高级顾问。此后，玛雅离开白宫，成为谷歌的首任行为洞察主管。
I told you at the start of this episode that Maya's story is a universal story. Now, not all of us are going to be concert violinists or road scholars or presidential advisers, but I don't think any of those things are the real point of Maya's story. The reason I wanted to tell you the story at the turn of a new year is because all of us have chapters in our lives that close and when they do, especially if it's a chapter we have known and loved for a long time, it can feel like the whole book is over that there's nothing left to do, maybe even nothing left to live for. But I think each of us has stories in our lives that reflect the fact that the people we are
我在本集节目开始时告诉你，玛雅的故事是一个普遍的故事。现在，我们并非所有人都能成为音乐会小提琴家、罗德学者或总统顾问，但我认为这些都不是玛雅故事真正的重点。我之所以想在新年伊始讲这个故事，是因为我们所有人的生活中都有合上章节的时候，当它们合上时，特别是如果这是一个我们长期了解和热爱的章节，它可能会让人觉得整本书都结束了，没有什么可做的了，甚至没有什么可活的了。但我认为我们每个人的人生中都有这样的故事，反映出这样一个事实：今天的我们
today are not the same people we were a few years ago. We often underestimate our capacity to reinvent ourselves. I was talking some years ago with Rick Potts, he's a paleoanthropologist and the head of the Smithsonian Institution's Human Origins program. And something he said stuck in my head, he told me that the thing that distinguished early humans from other species was our remarkable capacity to adapt to different conditions, different situations. Uniquely, humans live in very cold places and very hot places, at altitude and sea level, some of us live long periods underwater or even in outer space. Most of that isn't about our physical abilities, it's really about the mind. And each year, around
已经不是几年前的我们了。我们常常低估了自己重塑自我的能力。几年前，我与里克·波茨（Rick Potts）交谈过，他是一位古人类学家，也是史密森尼学会人类起源项目的负责人。他所说的一句话留在了我的脑海里，他告诉我，早期人类与其他物种的区别在于我们适应不同条件、不同局势的非凡能力。独特的是，人类生活在非常寒冷和非常炎热的地方，在高海拔和海平面，我们中的一些人长时间生活在水下甚至太空中。这大部分与我们的身体能力无关，真正关乎的是心灵。每年，
this time, we need to remind ourselves that as one door closes, we have the ability to find other doors to open. I want to leave you with a lovely poem by Elizabeth Bishop. Singer Amy Mann happened to be at NPR and we asked her to read the poem for us. One art by Elizabeth Bishop. The art of losing isn't hard to master. So many things seem filled with the intent to be lost, that their loss is no disaster. Lose something every day, except the fluster of lost door keys, the hour badly spent,
在这个时候，我们需要提醒自己，正如一扇门关闭时，我们有能力找到其他门去打开。我想留给你们伊丽莎白·毕晓普的一首可爱的诗。歌手艾米·曼恩碰巧在NPR，我们请她为我们朗诵这首诗。伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一门艺术》。失去的艺术并不难掌握。许多事情似乎都充满了被遗失的意图，以至于它们的丢失并不是灾难。每天失去一些东西，除了慌乱——丢失的门钥匙、虚度的小时，
the art of losing isn't hard to master. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster. I lost my mother's watch. And look, my last or next to last of three loved houses went. The art of losing isn't hard to master. I lost two cities' lovely ones, and Vastor, some realms I owned, two rivers a continent.
失去的艺术并不难掌握。然后练习更远、更快地失去，地点、名字以及你原本打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。我弄丢了我母亲的手表。看吧，我三座挚爱的房子中的最后一座或倒数第二座也消逝了。失去的艺术并不难掌握。我失去了两座可爱的城市，以及庞大广袤的帝国，我拥有的一些领域，两条河流，一个大陆。
I missed them, but it wasn't a disaster. Even losing you, the joking voice suggests your I love. I shant have lied. It's evident the art of losing is not too hard to master, though it may look like, write it, like disaster. That was Amy Mann, reading one art by Elizabeth Bishop. Amy was at NPR with Ted Leo to perform for the All Songs Considered Podcast. This episode was produced by Maggie Penman and Karamagurk Allison. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah, Raina Cohen, Laura Correll, Tara Boyle, Thomas
我想念它们，但这不是一场灾难。甚至失去你，那个开玩笑的声音暗示着我爱。我没有撒谎。很显然，失去的艺术并不算太难掌握，尽管它看起来可能像是一场灾难。那是艾米·曼恩朗诵伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一门艺术》。艾米与特德·利奥（Ted Leo）一起在NPR为《所有歌曲考虑》播客进行表演。本集由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）和卡拉·马古克·埃利森（Karamagurk Allison）制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕斯·沙阿（Parth Shah）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、托马斯
Liu and Kemela Vargas-Drestrepo. Our unsung hero this week is someone who helped me reinvent my own life. Paul Ginsburg is a longtime NPR supporter and donor. In December 2013, Paul came to me and told me I should be doing more than just weekly stories for radio. What about a podcast he asked? Paul did more than just simply toss out an idea. He helped to make it a reality. He raised funds to launch Hidden Brain and he's been a trusted friend and advisor ever since. More than time and money, Paul gave me what might be the most valuable gift one person can give another. He helped me see something in myself that I had not seen on my own. Thanks Paul.
·刘（Thomas Liu）和卡梅拉·巴尔加斯-雷斯特雷波（Kemela Vargas-Drestrepo）。我们本周的无名英雄是一位帮助我重塑自己生活的人。保罗·金斯伯格（Paul Ginsburg）是NPR的长期支持者和捐赠者。2013年12月，保罗找到我，告诉我我不应该只为广播做每周的故事。播客怎么样？他问道。保罗不仅仅是抛出一个想法。他帮助将其变为现实。他为启动《隐藏的大脑》筹集了资金，从那以后他一直是一个值得信赖的朋友和顾问。除了时间和金钱，保罗还给了我一个人能给另一个人最宝贵的礼物。他帮助我看到了自己身上没有独自发现的东西。谢谢你，保罗。
From everyone at Hidden Brain, we wish you new paths, new dreams, and much reinvention this coming year. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自《隐藏的大脑》的每个人，我们祝愿您在接下来的一年里拥有新的道路、新的梦想以及许多重塑。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。